clay what's your process for writing and
documentary as you're writing something
but in the same sense it's a real thing
that's happening yet to me it's it's
writing is is editing so like the editor
of a documentary is the writer and I
think that it's just you're crafting the
story out of pieces that already exist
and you're you know you're helping to
kind of craft these sound bites and and
lay out the story in conjunction with
the director as well that just happens
to be me in this instance as well I do
editing and directing so it's not that
I'm having conversations with myself all
the time but only in the car only in the
car yeah lots of voice memos to myself
but yeah I mean it really helps to in
the writing process to have people and a
sounding board to to help craft the
story because you get lost in it and for
me those sounding boards are Seth Gordon
and Mary rolek two of our other
producers and that's just you know
they've been with me on all the the
movies that I've made
Mary's also my wife so that there's some
some overlap there but little bit a
little bit and yeah we're just just
having that sort of that creative team
that you can bounce ideas off of and and
try to figure out what the best stories
to be told out of the pieces that you
were given
you